Франція давно не бачила такої єдності.
Перемога Еммануеля Макрона на президентських,
а тепер і парламентських виборах
має велике значення не лише для французів, але й для ЄС.
Прихильники виходу Франції з Євросоюзу
не змогли скласти конкуренцію проєвропейським силам.
У той час, як політсила Макрона та союзники
з "Демократичного руху" вибороли 350 місць в парламенті із 577,
"Національний фронт" Марін Ле Пен взяв лише 8 крісел.
У Брюсселі й Берліні привітали такі зміни політичного ландшафту.
Утім, успіх Макрона як політика
оцінюватимуть згодом -
залежно від того,
чи вдасться йому втілити найважливіші внутрішні реформи та виправдати високі очікування французів.
Гадаю, здобуття більшості місць в Національних зборах
є позитивним моментом, який принесе новий сценарій в країну.
Перша галузь реформ, гадаю, повинна бути у сфері зайнятості.
Ми повинні зробити ринок праці більш гнучким.
Також реформи мають стосуватися сфери безпеки.
Для нас, французів, це має велике значення.
Порівнюючи різні сфери, де потрібні реформи,
гадаю, найважливіше здійснити реформу освіти.
А тоді на додачу реформи в економіці.
Країні справді нагально необхідні реформи,
насамперед ринку праці, безпеки та освіти.
Передусім зміни у сфері зайнятості з упертими французами провести вкрай складно.
По суті, всі попередники Макрона упродовж останніх десятиліть
зазнали в цьому більших чи менших невдач.
Громадські протести є більш ніж звичним явищем у Франції.
Відповіді попередніх урядів на демонстрації були невідповідними.
Це може також стати на заваді здійсненню
та впровадженню політичних рішень для уряду Макрона.
Тепер від успішності політики Макрона
в наступні п'ять років залежить, перед яким вибором опиниться Франція
під час наступної виборчої кампанії.
Якщо французи розчаруються в проєвропейському кандидаті,
це може кинути тінь на ідею ЄС.